bonjour j'ai invité Philippe Labau pour
son livre édité chez galimar 7500
signes bonjour Philippe BLB merci d'être
là vous êtes journaliste réalisateur
plein de choses à la fois et là vous
nous livrez non pas un roman cette fois
mais un livre qui est un recueil de
chronique qui s'appelle 7500 signes
alors c'est un livre composé de
chroniques principalement écrites dans
le Figaro sur 3 années 2008 2010 qui
s'achève par une fiction et qui montre
bien au fond euh ce que vous êtes ce que
vous vouliez être ce que vous êtes
c'est-à-dire la jonction harmonieuse
entre le journalisme le roman il y a eu
aussi entre-temps le cinéma là nous
avons le journalisme et la fiction et ce
livre est d'ailleurs dédié à Tom Wolf je
me suis dit d'ailleurs d'habitude les
dédicaces des livres c'est à mon épouse
à ma femme à mes enfants et cetera ou
Tom Wolf mais expliquez-nous pourquoi
Tom Wolf Tom c'est d'abord un ami et
après tout pourquoi ne pas dédier un
livre à un ami mais surtout n'oublions
jamais que c'est un homme qui a
justement fait le passage éblouissant du
journalisme à la littérature avant
d'être le grand romancier du Bûcher des
vanités et autres volume Tom a été dans
les débuts des fin 50 début 60 un des
inventeurs de ce qu'on appelle le
nouveau journalisme où il libérait
totalement il allait sur le terrain
c'est un grand investigateur grand
enquêteur mais son écriture était très
subjective et sortait des normes
journalistiques avec norm mailer aidé
d'ailleurs par le génie de trumman
capotte qui l' à peu près la même époque
sort de s froid donc transformation qui
démontre ce que j'essaie de faire avec
ce livre que il y a pratiquement
pas de faussé entre le journalisme bien
écrit entre guillemets et le roman ça
c'est un quelque chose difficile à
admettre en France où on aime bien
ranger les gens dans des cases surtout
qu'ils n'en sortent pas et donc vous
montrez qu'au contraire aux ÉtatsUnis il
y a ce ce lien se fait plus en France
aussi hein je veux dire ailleurs aussi
mais néanmoins les choses sont plus dans
la culture américaine journalistique
américaine -même d'Ille oui Jean en même
temps en France l'exemple de C Roger
vaillant George Simenon et bien avant
Zola qui grands écrivain mais qui aussi
allait à la rencontre du réel et le
rapportait pour ensuite effectivement
aller dans l'imaginaire alors il y a
dans votre Avant Propos une petite leçon
aussi qui commence par oui qui commence
par ne jamais faire emmerdant oui mais
c'est une phrase que Tom m'a raconté un
jour au début à ses début oui à ses
début son rédacteur en chef lui dit
écoute vas-y parce il aimait beaucoup
balancer il faisait des fleuves de
longues phrases et tout avec des
onomatopé et il disait arrête-toi quand
ça devient emmerdant le problème c'est
qu'on n'est pas sûr soit d'être
emmerdant donc il vaut mieux qu' un
rédacteur en chef pour vous le dire en
tout cas je garantis que ce livre n'est
jamais emmerdant il y a beaucoup
d'Amérique évidemment qui est un de vos
sujets favoris et donc on va s'y arrêter
un instant sur l'Amérique d'abord parce
que vous-même vous il y a pas mal de
textes sur les États-Unis euh il y a
commençons par le commencement
quelque chose qui est très élogieux pour
Obama qui qui traduit d'ailleurs
l'émotion le l'enthousiasme l'espoir du
moment et puis quel un petit peu plus
loin vous nous montrez quelques-unes de
vos notes euh prises comme ça sur vos
petits carnets et où vous dites tout
d'un coup tiens attention à l'Obamania
les choses B et là le le retournement
est là terrible terrible ou donc on va
commenter un petit peu ces ces ces
élections avec votre regard avec ce ces
élections desm de terme on va peut-être
commencer par écouter un passage
significatif de ce qu'a dit Obama après
ces élections que je trouve très
significatif aussi de la culture
politique américaine je dire il ne se
cache pas pour assumer son échec on va
écouter Barack Obama ces deux dernières
années nous avons fait des progrès mais
à l'évidence trop d'Américains n'en ont
pas ressenti les effets pour l'instant
et c'est ce qu'ils nous ont dit hier en
tant que président j'en prends l'entière
responsabilité ce qui hier nous a aussi
appris c'est qu'aucun parti ne pourra
décider à lui seul où nous devons aller
nous devons trouver un terrain
d'entente pour affronter des défis
exceptionnels j'ai hâte de m'asseoir
avec les leaders des deux parties pour
voir comment nous pouvons aller de
l'avant
ensemble commentaire commentaire vous
avez vu une des raisons pour quel Obama
est suit une défaite c'est que cet homme
qui a fait une campagne électorale il y
a 2 ans extraordinaire a été à la
seconde où il est rentré à la maison
blanche figé dans un comportement à
cause du prompteur vous avez remarqué un
coup à droite un coup à gauche un coup à
droite il lit son texte et ça manque de
chaleur alors d'autres présidents se
servaient du prompteur tout le monde
s'en sert mais Clinton par exemple se
servait merveilleusement bien il y
mettait autre chose une humanité où il
s'arrêtait donc il a il y a eu un
problème de communication mais c'est
évidemment la raison c'est pas raison
pour laquelle les démocrates ont été
battus la raison pour laquelle ils ont
été battus c'est qu'au fond les
Américains avaient voté pour le
changement le changement arrive et soit
ils le trouvent différent de ce qu'ils
attendaient soit pas assez fort donc ils
sont mécontents ils étaient mécontent de
buou ils votent pour Obama ils sont
mécontents d'Obama et il y a une vague
de d'insatisfaction en Amérique très
violente et qui fait qu'ils n'ont pas de
mémoire ils ont déjà oublié ce qui s'est
passé il y a 2 ans ils veulent même pas
comprendre que Obama a essayé avec ses
hommes de faire en sorte que ça soit pas
une dépression et simplement une
récession car ils étaient au bord du
gouffre comme vous le savez bien
absolument mais dans ce dans cet extrait
qu'on a vu il y a aussi ces
caractéristiques de la vie publique
américaine je veux dire il il bon il
assume 1 il dit voilà c'est c'est ma
défaite c'est ma ma responsabilité mais
il y a aussi
aussitôt un appel à collaborer
travailler avec les avec les r question
c'est qu' pas le temps de vousz pas le
temps de le montrer c'est que répond
le nouveau leader du Congrès et le
leader enfin le leader de l'opposition
républicaine au Sénat ils disent très
bien on va essayer mais de toutes façons
nous serons au côté de ce gouvernement
s'il se comporte comme le peuple le veut
mais nous les confronterons s'il ne le
fait pas
c'est un programme assez vaste he et
certains même homes politiques
républicain dis notre seul objectif
c'est qu'il soit pas réélu en 2012 ça
veut dire qu'on peut avoir pendant 2 ans
une une immobilisation de l'activité
politique en Amérique qui peut être très
très dangereuse pour l'Amérique et même
accessoirement pour le reste du monde du
monde absolument absolument alors il
faut peut-être rappeler que d'autres
présidents ont subi ce que vient de
subir Barack Obama commencé par Ronald
ran mais aussi Bill Clinton et George
Bush Bill Clinton lui aussi démocrate
mais Bill Clinton avait dû affronter
chambre des démocrates et Chambre des
Représentants et Sénat hostile et il
avait laissé tomber son programme
Obama veut quand même garder au
fond l'essentiel son program on va voir
ça va être très intéressant euh il va
mettre sans doute nous démontrer ENF qui
il est quelle est sa vraie nature est-il
un centriste est-il capable de balance
ça c'est le grand terme vous le savez le
fameux terme check and balance vérifier
et équilibré est-il capable d'équilibrer
en face il y a quand même des des hommes
politiques raisonnables et intelligents
mais il y a aussi des extrémistes qui
sont arrivver qui arrive à washon vous
on le on le parcourt aussi à travers ce
ce ces chroniques vous connaissez pas de
l'Amérique que Washington vous
connaissez
l'Amérique y compris l'Amérique profonde
comment expliquez-vous à la fois cette
il y a une part quand même de haine
ouais vis-à-vis d'Obama oui donc est-ce
que c'est tout simplement un réflexe
raciste racial qui ressurgit en partie
en partie et et comment expliquez-vous
en même temps ce phénomène avec lequel
on va vivre pour quelques solides années
me semble-t-il qui est le phénomène
d'idti partis qui est un phénomène
j'allais dire populop populiste mais
mais plus radical peut-être que ce que
nous connaissons en Europe très radical
et sans véritable projet politique
Jean-Marie sans véritable programme
c'est le
rejet d'Obama en tant qu'homme mais
aussi ce qu'il a essayé de faire avec
cette fameuse loi sur le système de
santé américain qui avait besoin d'être
réformé alors sa réforme peut-être
imparfaite incomplète mais enfin elle
existe mais et elle a été refusée par
une communauté il faut bien voir le type
parti c'est une
communauté blanche totalement blanche et
de la Bible Belt la ceinture la Bible
c'est beaucoup le sud et le Sud-Ouest
c'est une
réaction et sans doute pas seulement à
cause d'Obama mais parce qu'il y a une
peur extraordinaire face à la Chine face
aux délocalisations face au manque de
Job le problème numéro 1 c'est l'emploi
ils sont à peu près maintenant à 10 % de
chômage ce qui est inattendu aux
États-Unis et donc le TIP parti ne fait
que comment dirje ramasser résumer
synthétiser le mécontentement ce sont
des mécontents et alors on fait appel au
drapeau à l'héritage américain à la
Constitution en essayant de faire passer
des messages abérrents selon quoi Obama
n'est même pas né aux États-Unis que
tout ce qu'il a fait jusqu'ici c'est
antionstitution n anti-américain alors
qu'il a essayé à sa manière de faire une
réforme un peu rosevaltienne
donc bien sûr il y arrive pas bien sûr
ils ont commis des graves erreurs à la
Maison Blanche enfin cela dit il est
surtout handicapé par le calendrier
aussi parce que on on fait souvent
référence à roswelt en effet mais
Roosevelt quand il arrive au pouvoir il
s'est passé 3 ans entre le début de la
crise et le moment où il arrive au
pouvoir et donc les dégâts sont là les
dégâts de la crise sont là palpables
alors que quand Obama arrive au pouvoir
je veux dire la notamment l'explosion du
chômage est naissante donc on la lui
impute alors que on devrait normalement
l'imputer à la crise oui mais ENF
d'accord Colombani il est au commande il
est président depuis 2 ans il peut pas
toujours dire c'est les autres j'ai
hérité d'un problème qui que alors il y
a autre chose aussi qu'on ne soulligne
jamais assez c'est que au fond le
système politique américain fait qu'ils
sont tout le temps en campagne
électorale tout le temps absolument
alors ils sont en campagne pour être
président à peine élu il faut qu'il
pense aux élections mi mandat qui sont
que 2 ans plus tard donc en réalité à
mon avis un président quel qu'il soit il
a 2 ans pour faire passer ses réformes
et ses décisions parce qu'ensuite le
miandat ça ouvre évidemment sur la
présidentielle de 2012 il ne parle déjà
que de ça commence à penser à Madame
Sarah Paline il y a des noms qui
apparaissent inconnus pour nous mais en
Amérique c'est pas grave ils ont
démontrer qu'en 6 mois un gouverneur
inconnu l'arcansas Bill Clinton peut
devenir une super det et donc désormais
c'est ça qui va compter et d'ailleurs
l'un d'entre eux a dit ouvertement et
crumement mon notre seul objectif et de
faire en sorte qu'il ne soit président
que d'un mandat un point à la ligne oui
absolument donc on va vers quoi ce qui
s'appelle peut-être le gridlock c'està
le verou tout va être bloqué tout
pourrait être bloqué tout pourrait être
bloqué dans un tout pourrait être bloqué
parce qu' attention c'est pas la peine
de prédire quoi que ce soit parce que
qui il y a 2 ans pouvait nous prédire
qu'il allait prendre une telle claque
oui d'une part et qui aurait pu prédire
qu'il aurait été élu encore Mo parce que
ça ça restera quoi qu'il arrive pour moi
c'est quand même l'élément plus positif
qui explique pourquoi effectivement ma
première chronique sur Obama était tout
aussi élogieuse et enthousiaste c'est
qu'Ant eu très jeune étudiant étranger
en Virginie é était le témoin de ce qui
était la ségrégation moi personnellement
Jean-Marie Colombani j'ai été bouleversé
parce que je ne pouvais pas imaginer que
quoi 40 50 ans plus tard un noir un
métis entre la Maison Blanche ça ça
restera quoi qu'il arrive enfin ça ne
suffit pas oui ça y est c'est dans
l'histoire américaine tout à fait
maintenant ils sont là ils sont face à
des problèmes très compliqués vastes il
s'en va faire un voyage en Asie il est
président des États-Unis le pays entre
guillemets le plus puissant du monde
même s'il ne l'est plus véritablement le
plus puissant donc il a une politique
étrangère assumer il y a le traité avec
la Russie sur les armes nucléaires le ce
fameux start est-ce que le Sénat va le
laisser passer il y a pas mal
d'interrogations hein donc ça va être
assez passionnant et en terme d'opinion
d'ailleurs quand on regarde les sondages
sortis des urnes sont intéressant parce
que le parti républicain qui vient de
gagner la Chambre des Représentants n'a
pas une si bonne image non et Obama a
une meilleure image et un meilleur
souhait en tout cas autour d'Obama
encore aujourd'hui plutôt que du côté
républicain siil est un politicien
habile
roué malin
sachant will and deal come on dit hein
négocier compromettre compromis on
accepte on refuse de temps en temps on
montre sa main de fer il est tout à fait
rééligligible mais là encore moi je peux
rien prédire oui et dans dans l'ordre de
des comparaisons il y a aussi évidemment
Bill Clinton qui avait dû batailler et
qui avait passé beaucoup de compromis
mais néanmoins qui avait été combattu
d'une façon absolument hallucinante par
les alors qu'aujourdhui pu ces mêmes
républicains font l'éloge de Bill
Clinton et oppose la figure de Bill
Clinton à celle de Barack Obama mais
petit retour en arrière pour qui est
peut-être en train aussi de ressurgir
avec les TI partis il y avait quand même
une formidable vague de puritanisme en
même temps qui qui qui était anti
Clinton anti 68 anti tout ce qu'on ce
qu'on voudra ça reste un grand ressort
américain oui bien sûr le petit parti
vous avez eu des candidates en
particulier parce que c'est un événement
nouveau aussi c'est le nom de femmes qui
sont porté la candidature et donc
certaines d'entre elles n'avaient
strictement aucune culture politique à
peine du vocabulaire simplement elle
ressemblait elle rassemblait elle
ressemblait elle elle symbolisait les
mamans les mamans américaines mais l'une
d'entre elles tu sait qu'il fallait
faire une loi contre la masturbation oui
absolument c'est la plus célèbre d'entre
elles c'est christineel il y a de quoi
être célèbre pour une énormité pareil
absolument
c'est quand même sur la scène politique
américaine mais ne les ridiculisons pas
he in n'exagérons pas non plus les
débats sont
importants effectivement l'économie
c'est ça qui prime absolument j'ai
remarqué aussi tout le M l'a remarqué
pas un mot sur l'Afghanistan il y a
quand même une guerre en Afghanistan et
qui coûte des milliards pas un mot coû
des milliards il y a des soldats qui
meurent il y a des gens qui meurent
américains qui meurent différence entre
Bush et Obama c'est qu'Obama quand le
cercueil arrivve il est là pour les les
saluer et il laisse photographier les
cérémonies alors que rappelez-vous
l'administration B C les cercueils cacha
les cercueils so é c'est pas une
mauvaise administration comme on dit
hein puisque c'est le terme
administration c'est le terme pour
gouvernement en fait oui ça n'est pas un
mauvais gouvernement c'est pas la
question la question c'est
qu'effectivement ils ont ils sont face à
un peuple à une nation très divisée très
divisée parce que Ty parti c'est une
partie de l'Amérique c'est absolument
pas l'Amérique moderne regardez ce qui
se passe en Californie c'est très
intéressant la Californie la Californie
a voté contre le reste des Ty parti
parce que Jerry Brown qui est à nouveau
élu gouverneur pour la trè fois de sa
vie son existence c'est un écologiste
c'est un moderne c'est un garçon qui est
prêt à faire beaucoup beaucoup de
concession justement et est à l'inverse
au contraire ce puritanisme dont vous
parlez donc c'est des contradictions
c'est United States les état unis ou
alors ils sont unis quand ils sont
attaqués quand il y a une immense crise
ou au contraire quand il y a un
mouvement d'enthousiasme mais le reste
temps il y a une grande division et il y
a un mouvement que l'on retrouve aussi
en Europe qui consiste à dire dès lors
que on est riche d'ailleurs ou ou
appartenant à une région riche on veut
plus payer pour les régions pauvres et
ainsi de suite et ce phénomène là est
aussi très présent aux États-Unis où on
dénonce Washington en disant mais ils
utilisent mal notre argent et cetera
c'est c'est vraiment très très
particulier mais pas pas
si comment dire pas si original que cela
parce qu'on voit ça dans la Ligue du
Nord en Italie on voit ça en Belgique du
côté de du parti flamand et puis on voit
s'installer aussi en Europe un pe petit
peu ce ce courant la la question la
dernière question sur l'Amérique que je
voulais vous poser c'est qu' il y a une
grande porosité toujours entre les vies
public et vous disiez ne ne les
ridiculonsons pas en effet parce que
souvent on importe et il y a un petit
temps de latence entre le moment où un
mouvement d'idée se déploie aux
États-Unis où il s'installe ensuite en
Europe euh je suis pas certain qu' pu y
avoir un pe parti en France c'est pas la
même chose parce que ti parti il
reviennent en permanence à la
constitution au au père fondateur au
fait que en gros pas de gouvernement
attention à l'état AC un majuscule on n
pas besoin d'un État fort au contraire
libération du marché c'est pas du tout
la même chose en France ne comparons pas
le réflexe en France c'est plutôt de
demander à l'État de faire quelque chose
demander tout à l'étatou de demander
tout à l'état alors au fil de cette
promenade où il y a donc pas mal
d'Amérique on vient on vient d'en parler
il y a aussi il y a tous vos tous vos
thèmes favoris écrivains femmes
euh y compris pris aussi quelques-unes
de vos petites notes sur vos sur sur vos
carnets et puis des puis quelques
inédits aussi des chroniques oui je
voulais je voulais insérer un texte qui
était un hommage à mon ami Jacques
lancman alorsqu'il a disparu qui est
paru d'ailleurs dans le temps moderne
sfire Claude av décidé de publier dans
temps moderne un texte tout à fait
inédit sur mon père comme ça que je
voulais mettre pour justement montrer
que l'écriture va dans tous les sens et
quelques textes où alors là au contraire
je suis sorti du carcan des 7506 et j'ai
déliré à la Tom Wolf en particulier sur
les années 60 sur les sixties oui
absolument et enfin cette petite fiction
une nouvelle ouais et avant d'en venir à
la nouvelle dans dans le votre galerie
de qui sont toutes vos curiosités au
fond il y a il y a un article
intéressant et étonnant sur Johnny
alidday alors ce qui ramène à une petite
partie de votre vie aussi parce que vous
avez été un des paroliers de Johnny donc
vous le connaissez mieux que tout un
chacun mais en tout cas vous donnez un
éclairage très original sur la figure de
mer beaucoup oui parce que c'est un
personnage très intéressant plus
compliqué qu'on croit plus complexe qu'
un instinct une intelligence du publique
extraordinaire oui vous lui donnez une
profondeur qu'on ne qu'on lui attribue
pas nécessairement on a tort oui un
grand artiste aussi populaire qui a duré
aussi longtemps a forcément une sorte de
profondeur bien sûr oui bien sûr et et
vous-même vous aviez évidemment écrit
aussi écrit pour lui j'ai essayé de lui
faire quelques textes 70 on en a fait
d'autres depuis et euh je continue
d'avoir très grande amitié pour pour ce
garçon dont la capacité de survie est
quand même prodigieuse absolument et
surtout euh oublions jamais l'artiste
sur scène il a évolué il a il il a MRI
ouais la petite voix un peu fluette qui
chantait l'idole des jeunes et qui
aujourd'hui nous lance du Piaf du brê ou
bé il peut chanter ce qu'il veut à
l'idée aujourd'hui avec la maturité de
sa voix c'est toujours remarquable ouais
tu un très bon chanteur oui oui tout à
fait euh il y a bon vous aimez aussi
beaucoup la musique donc on retrouve pas
beaucoup de chroniques sur des concerts
ou sur des des événements lyriques ou
musicaux intéressants mais mais le le le
régal de ces chroniques c'est une
chronique que vous consacrez à ce que
vous appelez l'armée des tousseurs ah
oui alors d'ailleurs et quand on vous
lit on dit mais bon sens c'est vrai
quand on est au spectacle il y a
toujours un moment où il y a des comme
ça des des vagues de qui sont d'ailleurs
euh presque coordonné oui c'est pour ça
que j'ai j'ai j'ai imaginé que c'était
une armée invisible mais qui avait ses
repères qui avait sa stratégie ce son
anentrisme on les voit pas rentrer dans
la salle ils ont pas d'uniforme ni rien
mais ils sont disposés au quatre coins
de la salle et c'est les rafales ils
balancent leurs glaviaot leur tout leurs
érupctations c'est une horreur alors je
me suis amusé à trouver tous les termes
pour définir ça au point qu'un soir
c'est ça qui m'avait obligé à à faire ce
papier ça fait très longtemps que ça
m'exaspérait j'ai complètement oublié la
musique c'était Polini qui jouit du bac
c'était génial sauf que comme
pratiquement toute je me suis mis à
compter les intervalles pendant lesquels
il y avait pas de tout donc je j'étais
plus dans dans la musique et j'en ai
tiré ce ce papier qui m'a valu
tenez-vous bien beaucoup plus de
réaction que des portraits plus sérieux
sur les hommes politiques des écrivains
ce que vous voulez des événements graves
là d'un seul coup tout oui bravo vous
avez raison mais c'est vrai que c'est
une particularité insupportable en
France en France ou
voilles souvent plusueux absolument
beaucoup de choses consacrées aux femmes
oui alors vous en distinguez quelques
une oui alors il y a il y a aussi aussi
des très sérieux euh mais le texte le
plus touche enfin le plus émouvant est
sans doute celui que vous consacrez aux
infirmières bon là aussi c'est relié à
une part de votre histoire personnelle
dont vous aviez tiré d'ailleurs euh un
livre ou lorsque vous aviez été en
quinzaine de jours en réanimation Ahou
et à traversexte vous
réhabilitez l'héroïme vrai finalement
c'estd l'héroïme au quotidien j'ai
effectivement je vous remercie beaucoup
de signaler pour moi c'est c'est c'est
le texte un des textes dont je suis le
plus fier ne pas le terme auquel
j'accorde le plus d'importance car
c'était à partir d'un fait d'hiver vous
souvenez il y a 2 ans ça arrive
malheureusement de temps en temps une
erreur une erreur épouvantable une
infirmière qui au la mort de je crois
c'est un enfant et alors évidemment AR
sur infirmière terrible et et je je me
suis mis dans la peau de cette femme et
puis j'ai dit écoutez attendez un peu je
vais vous expliquer ce que c'est que les
infirmières moi elles m'ont sauvé la vie
avec les médecins bien sûr a les aides
soignantes avec tout le corps médical
mais ce sont les héroïnes du quotidien
elles sont mal payé c'est une vocation
hein c'est pas un métier elles viennent
parce qu'elles ont eu à un moment donné
de leur jeunesse une envie un désir
d'aider euh et et de sauver des vies et
de contribuer à faire en sorte que ça
aille mieux et j'ai je me suis souvenu
de l'une d'entre elles qui lorsque
j'étais au plus mal en pleine
réanimation à Cochin entre deux comas
artificiels et qui essayit de de me
soulager ma gorge parce que j' une
machine qui respirait à ma place c'était
assez insupportable et qui voyant que je
résistais parce qu'on résiste toujours
et que j'avais peur et que je souffrais
m'a dit avec une délicatesse inouie
j'essaie d'atteindre votre palais oui
j'ai trouvé ça bouleversant
d'intelligence
de choix des mots oui oui de douceur qui
m'a d'ailleurs détendu et elle a pu
atteindre mon palais et c'était ça mon
papier et alors là aussi effectivement
j'ai eu beaucoup de réaction j'ai même
ça ça me fait très plaisir un professeur
à Strasbourg qui a fait imprimer le
papier et l' affiché sur tous les murs
de l'hôpital oui absolument et bon à
côté de ça évidemment il y a des il y a
des sujets plus politique il y a
évidemment la quelques portraits
quelques portraits oui tout à fait oui
et je vais toujours essayer de chercher
ceux qui ne sont pas forcément en bonne
situation c'est je fait importer
François Baayou quand il avait essuyé
cette défaite il y a un an 1 an et demi
François Hollande au moment où il quitte
le PS euh c'estolen Royal entre deux
entre deux show au zénites mais j'ai pas
été chercher les gens qui sont au
pouvoir parce que d'abord un journal est
plein de cela et moi mon regard c'est
plutôt oui mes choix très subjectifs
d'ailleurs tout à fait la chance que
j'ai c'est que je parle de ce que je
veux oui puis en même temps ces
personnes que vous citez quand les gens
sont euh ou ou ou sur le bord de la
route ou ou maltraité ou bref pour
différentes raisons euh c'est là qu'ils
sont intéressants parce qu'ils se
livrent davantage finalement heinûr bien
sûr mais c'est une règle absolue je veux
direou r universelle universelle moi je
me souviens de jackes shirac quand il
était à l'hôtel de ville après sa
défaite de 88 céta c'était là qu'il
était le plus bavard ouais et le plus
intéressant d'ailleurs mais ensuite dès
qu'il retrouve du pouvoir les mêmes
redeviennent insupportbles je crois que
vous l'avez
vous pouvez en témoigner tout autant ou
ce livre est aussi un un un livre
d'histoire au fil du temps donc ça nous
permet au fond de de
revivre très très vite
euh et de recapter l'air du temps donc
vous avez pas mal de chroniques comme ça
que vous appelez l'air du temps et et
donc vous choisissez à chaque fois un
événement que vous considérez comme
significatif sur le Boban d'ailleurs il
faut donc un un peu de arver oui il m
arrivver d'avoir la prétenenstion de de
de le faire par des saisons quand quand
tu un changement de saison après tout
nos vies dépendent essentiellement de
cela aussi ou tout d'un coup je me dis
ben je vais faire c'est le devoir de
classe c'est la
rédaction une composition on appelle ça
une composition de français vous
souvenez donc le printemps ça signifie
quoi mais à ce moment-là je vais
chercher des exemples au Japon les
corisiers dans le Colorado où l'ours
sort en face sa
tanière c'est presque bucolique
écologique ça rien à voir avec ce qu'on
appelle le journalisme courant mais
c'est ça la le privilège de quelqu'un
qui à sa disposition cette page entière
qu'on me donne chaque semaine dans LE
FIGARO c'est parler oui il y a pas
d'autres terme vous avez raison
Jean-Marie Colomb dit et c'est lazareev
qui l'avait inventé ou en tout cas qui
l'avait mis en exerg de l'airire du
temps de quoi est fait notre temps de
choses tout à fait effémère tout à fait
précaire et en même temps il y a des
tendances fortes qui ne bougent pas
effectivement quand la lumière baisse en
novembre un sentiment différent s'empare
des gens parfois malaise parfois
morosité c'est terrible mois de novemb
terrible pour les présidents des
États-Unis c'est terrible pour tout le
monde et ça aussi j'essaie de le sortir
du journalisme pur et donc on n'est pas
loin de l'écriture littéraire et vous
terminez d'ailleurs par une fiction
d'ordinaire d'ailleurs vous livrez un
roman une fiction là vous es plus réduit
alors oui c'est une nouvelle que j'avais
écrite pour elle il y a une bne dizaine
d'années qui s'appelle le garçon de bain
et qui est en fait un récit sur la
jalousie féminine qui peut se terminer
par des chos terribles et vu par un
garçon de bain qui travaille dans un
grand hôtel en été au bord d'un grand
lac et il se trouve que certains de mes
amis qui sont pas forcément mes amis ou
qui me critiquent souvent ou qui même à
moitié me disent c'est ton meilleur
texte oui donc un compliment je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit un compliment
cela dit cela dit c'est c'est en même
temps euh je dire ça a une nécessité
dans ce livre parce que c'est retour à
l'introduction ça explique exactement
encore une fois ce que vous voulez faire
entre le lien entre l'écriture
journalistique l'écriture littéraire la
littérature trois règles ne jamais
tremmerdant un bon début et une bonne
fin il y a toujours ça dans un papierre
et si possible informer quand même
apprendre quelque chose apprendre
quelque chose absolument c'est la base
on apprend soi et ensuite on transmet
transmet ce que vous fait en ce moment
absolument c'est la base et puis il y a
aussi cette appétit que vous avez en
permanence voilà quand on vous donne
7500 signes voilà en soi il y a déjà une
mais c'est bien parce qu'on dit voilà
hein tu remets le papier vendredi 17h
pas 17h30 et moi j'étais formé comme ça
hein éloge du journalisme merci Philippe
Labau donc ce livre 7500 signe édité
chez galimar pour celles et ceux d'entre
vous qui souhaitez retrouver les propos
de Philippe Labau rendez-vous évidemment
à tout moment sur
publicsenat.fr puis